mystic river
i have no problem admitting when i'm
wrong like the time like the one time i
got married stay single and have a happy
life you'll spare the children from a
life of emotional abuse
they will be taught to hate you that's
what a lot of men find out is
so what he's talking about there is
parental alienation
and parental alienation sucks because
as i scroll up over here where was 150k
dude this guy spent 150
000 to see his kids to not be pushed out
of their lives
what this guy's describing here uh
is what a lot of moms do where they try
to manufacture indignation
uh between the child or children and the
father
and they'll make it seem like he's a bad
guy he was an inattentive father he was
abusive
i've heard stories where mothers make up
stories about
how the father would hit you when you're
a baby or abuse you
none of these things ever happened but
whatever they can get away with that
will support
their story will be used
like the gentleman earlier said never
sign a contract while the other party is
rewarded for breaking it
there's no contract in business
in corporate in any other arena that
i've ever come across
anyway where there's a big incentive for
one of the two parties to break the
contract
and that's what family law does it
incentivize
the mother to break the contract and
richly rewards her in many different
ways alimony child support
you know using false allegations to gain
control
there's lots of things that happen all
of them i break down in great detail in
that chapter of the book so
definitely take a look at it if marriage
is something that you're contemplating
at least if you're gonna walk into the
slaughterhouse do it with your eyes wide
open is what i always tell guys
you